voilà ministre de la culture a grades
chevalier
légion d'honneur gabriela boda 40 ans de
service à le choc mercredi 16 février
gabriela bodha a été fait chevalier de
l'ordre de la légion d'honneur au
conservatoire de musique et de danse de
trappes grande chef de choeur
international elle a été récompensé pour
son investissement pour l'association de
la promotion de la musique de saint
quentin en yvelines d'origine hongroise
ce sont ses parents qui lui ont fait
aimer la musique dès son plus jeune âge
pour chanter dans l'église avec ma mère
on est en joie du jazz parallèlement à
l'école navale écoute de musique elle se
forme avec les plus grands chefs de
choeur et sort diplômé du conservatoire
national de débit cren elle poursuit
ensuite sa carrière en partant maroc en
chine en inde où elle travaille avec
tous les publics jeunes adultes amateurs
professionnels elle revient finalement
en france et devient en 2015 la nouvelle
chef de choeur de la pléiade de trappes
la légion d'honneur représente donc une
consécration je suis super heureuse je
suis très très ému très touché par cette
distinction c'est c'est la
reconnaissance de la france 2
pas seulement de mon travail parce que
ce que je fais c'est toujours un
réussite d'une équipe les enfants et le
président de l'association pour la
promotion de la musique de saint quentin
en yvelines sont tous très fiers de
cette distinction
gabriela
formidable là elle a fait un travail
absolument énorme et puis ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est que c'est un travail de
terrain j'ai été très contente pour elle
et c'est pas du coup j'étais contente
d'avoir une prof comme ça dans ma tâche
voshix c'est une professeur en dirai
c'est la mère professeur de trappes et
coeur dire hey mama avoir une médaille
de du président macron ses deux fils
marwan al anis étaient aussi présents
ils ont démontré à leur manière que la
musique chez les bouddhas est une
véritable histoire de famille
[Musique]